Josefa Califano jr. your book inside a
public and private life you mentioned on
many many pages the fact that you're a
Catholic why was that important to you
in this book well it it really you know
it's very much a part of me and it's
very much a part of what I've done I
mean my parents brought me up Catholic a
terrific Jesuit education it's stuck
with me and all through my life it's
it's really been the moral compass and I
think also it it affected what I
believed I mean I really believed for
example during the Great Society years
with with Lyndon Johnson but what we're
doing was right I mean it was sort of it
was morally right it wasn't just
something we were doing and it gave me a
lot of angst ooh I mean there's no
question about it especially at a TW all
those difficult issues abortion
sterilization DNA fetal research I mean
cloning and the struggle between what I
believe as a Catholic and how do you act
in a pluralistic society how do you know
where you are you're your objective you
can even spreche your view what you
believe which I did but then Congress
acts or the president acts or somebody
makes a decision you got to decide you
know executed or get out and it is it is
a part of my life and what does it mean
to be a Catholic Oh to me I mean it it
means that I have a terrific sense of
the every human being was created as a
creature of God created with dignity
with an inherent dignity it means that
it it you have to as you live your life
give to God what's his and Caesar what's
his that's and that's not easy in public
life especially today it's getting more
and more difficult and I think it means
that you have to say I'm accountable i
mean i think one of the things you know
people say oh you've done a wonderful
thing you've started a center on diction
subsidies or you've done this right but
you know in reality
I think you know God's given me
incredible talents if there's some
terrible struggles with cancer he's
given me good health why what's the
purpose of it why am I here well I'm
ultimately I'll be held accountable to
him and and that's one of the reasons
why I done a lot of the things I've done
to cancers what were they I had colon
cancer I had I was just starting the
National Center on addiction and
substance abuse at Columbia University
in 1992 and woke up one morning found
blood in my stool or and found out I had
cancer I couldn't believe it I mean I
know I guess we all think we're we're
just immortal nothing's ever going to
happen to us and and you know going to
the surgeon and as a right trying the
book you know you I would find myself
looking at the surgeons hands when I'm
interviewing him and thinking back how
many ask how many times you perform this
operation because I knew from the days
at agw the more surgeons do something
the better they are and then he'd say
well you know I don't know whether
you'll have to have a colostomy and I
that just shook me to the mara my mind
said what is that and he said well you
know it's a bag tied to your leg but you
get used to it if your stomach isn't
function your bowels are functioning it
just shook me so I you know I went to
the Catholic Church's you know and then
I you know getting the leg so good it's
a sacrament of the sick now is what is
called it was called extreme unction
when I was a kid in elementary school
but getting that sitting lying in New
York Hospital and all I could think of
was the world war two movies where the
priests were giving extra me monk shin
to the guys that were dead or Lord or
near dead on the battlefield and then
and I was at night and also as a little
there's a point which was little and
grooms langri had go out I said we know
why would you do this to me now what I'm
about to start this Center which I think
can do a lot of good for people that are
addicted or have problems okay so i
pulled out of that in about a year
what year is at first operation 1992 12
years ago it was 12 years ago and to
give you a sense I mean I was I had the
operation and I was right before our
first dinner introducing the center on
addiction and subsidies to the New York
Community trying to put on the agenda of
people like Barbara Walters and Peter
Jennings and his whole array of people
and get them interested in it and could
I go to the dinner could and I barely
made dinner you have a hospital two days
before the dinner and at the dinner had
to wear a diaper to gay because there's
no no sense of whether I had it wouldn't
have any control and then actually as a
point on the book remarkable as i'm
leaving the dinner i'm i've gotten
through it went well Peter Jennings says
to me I don't know what's wrong with you
because Barbara Walters had said you
know she come on up here and show us
your score so Peter Jennings successor
even AZ he said I don't know what what
everybody's talking about he said you've
never looked better and my wife Hillary
who spent years trying to get me to lose
weight Jeff seeing the elbow Jesus as
you see see what losing 20 pounds does
for you the first cancer in 92 did you
go through chemotherapy I did after
after the operation and that's that that
was the second scare we have the
operation out and it doctor says to me
will you have and what they call stage 3
or C stage cancer and I watch my wife's
face go ashen and I said oh this is
something and then he said but you know
it's that means that something's gotten
outside the intestine something I've got
started to slip out into the lymph nodes
and I got what was then very
experimental adjutant chemotherapy was
an experimental chemotherapy a doctor
dr. wolf up in New York and I go there I
and I at all this time incidentally and
every I got this the chemo every week
I exercise like crazy because I wanted
to make sure that I could maintain my
energy because I didn't I didn't tell a
soul that was the other thing I couldn't
tell I didn't want a soul to know I was
just beginning to raise money I would
just be any recruit people I thought to
myself God how am I got any of the best
people in the country to work- if they
think I may not be around in here so
everything was done in secrecy I'm into
the hospital under a different name
joseph anthony i had that rare
experience for anyone that lives in New
York of having a doctor that said don't
worry I'll get you in and out within
half an hour and he did and it was
always at an odd hour so it was it was a
it was a traumatic experience then when
did you get prostate cancer prostate
cancer a few years ago I was well I I
did actually the press they can't we
sort of did phase 1 i've got the center
organized were racing my about to go
into the second phase of raising money
and the center's called by the way the
national center on addiction and
substance abuse at columbia university
we call it casa the concept is to get is
very briefly i'll get the answer your
question concept is to get all the
different skills not just medicine law
but epidemiology and economics and
statistics in public health and social
ordinary to look at look at the issue as
addiction all substances alcohol drugs
pills performance-enhancing substance
prescription bills and look at in every
part of society that no place in the
world was doing that or is this day not
just the criminal justice system in
health care but schools are in so we're
in ran to just beginning and dr. Nash
boy I a doctor notices that that my PSA
has gone up and he says it's still
within the normal range but it's a big
jump and maybe it's maybe it's bacteria
or I'll give you an antibiotic but it
didn't go down and kept going up so he
said you need you need you need to be
treated and then the issue is whether to
have an operation or to have radiation
and I went through all the egg and you
go through trying to pick one or the
other and again I picked radiation at
Memorial sloan-kettering dr. Lee Bell
and he
he again I was given to me very early in
the morning so nobody would know I told
no the only person that knew this was my
wife for many years actually until I
wrote this book I think my wife and then
I told my three biological children
because I wanted to make sure they were
getting tests for colon cancer but and
you know thank God that that was a few
years ago coming and I'm okay I from
reading the book couple quick things you
were married to Trudy for 23 years had
three children married Hillary you're
originally from brooklyn how many years
of catholic school 16 years i had the
st. Gregory's elementary school 35 kids
nuns you know they'd slap you on the
knuckles with the ruler never never
never really hurt that much but was
always done in front of the class the
nuns always understood the deterrence of
embarrassment for a little kid and then
I went to Brooklyn prep which was a
Jesuit High School in Brooklyn and then
to holy cross college which was a Jesuit
college and found the Jesuits to be
fantastic teaching and those days you
graduated you majored in philosophy how
many years were your Washington lawyer
in the mixed of all is uh I came back
well I Kate you know I first came down
eyes all kinds of Washington lawyers i
mean i was i was in the Judge Advocate
General's Corps on the Navy defending
criminals I then I then went to New York
practice very briefly was in the
Pentagon as a lawyer for a while before
i became McNamara's assistant you were
in tomm do his law firm I was in time do
his law firm in New York at Dewey
Ballantine and I thought I'd love it but
I was I was insured or what a really
bored to death I mean I felt in many
ways i was making help money for people
already had more money than I could ever
spend in their life and I had one of
those you know one of those sort of
defining moments the DuPont family was
ordered to divest itself of control
General Motors and it required the
biggest stock split in the history of
the country for them to make marketable
the stock in the company through which
they control General Motors and I was
the youngest guy
the totem pole on that and worked for
weeks and weeks really it's a high-class
proofreader there were no paralegals in
those days file the papers with the SEC
and the partner in charge Stuart Scott
had this dinner at the this brent been
brand new philip johnson restaurant the
four seasons in New York and as a
classic Wall Street dinner you know five
courses lots of drinks lots of wine
brandy thean and toasting with this
brandy snifter at the end he said you
know you're the luckiest lawyer in this
law firm maybe on Wall Street he said I
prayed practicing wolf for 35 years and
this is the greatest experience of my
life I came home that night I said this
is the top I want no part of it so I
wrote a letter to side Vance and came
down went to that went to the Pentagon
as I've answered that the side Vance was
general counsel of the Defense
Department I wrote a letter on a
Wednesday it was in those days the mail
worked on Friday morning he called me up
I sent her a resume called me up on
friday morning and asked me to come down
on saturday i got an airplane the flu
down he interviewed me the longest
interview of my life a couple of hours
was was stunning to me to go through
something like that a Chuck took me by
to touch Bob McNamara's hand who was a
secretary of defense and then offered me
this job as his assistant to to to
really you know for the reorganization
of Pentagon what year this is 1961 it's
just not quite 30 years old but it was
you know the Pentagon we all think of
McNamara's Vietnam but in the early days
we were turning the place upside down my
analogy would be I felt like I was one
of those young lawyers in the Roosevelt
administration that's lesson she wrote
about I mean and one of those remarkable
experiences I mean McNamara said why are
the individual for services all buying
their stuff separately why don't we buy
it together through a defence
procurement agency and really get
bargain prices all the services oppose
that so he had this big meeting in his
office and he had all the Joint Chiefs
of Staff there in the service
secretaries there and we came in the
others that with four of us or work
with these huge peg boards and hanging
from the peg boards we'd have the Marine
Corps brassiere the army brassiere the
Navy brassiere the Air Force brassiere
and we have different underwear a
different belts different toilet seats
different pans that was incredible and
McNamara said why do we have to what's
the difference between all these things
and the Commandant of the Marine Corps
said the Marine Corps belt buckle is the
only belt buckle that can be used as a
bottle opener and it was a little
tittering and at that moment everyone in
that room no McNamara would create the
defense procurement agency and he did
the next day you went to Holy Cross then
where'd you get your law degree Harvard
and that would so you're at the Pentagon
you've got a Harvard Law degree you're
working for science eventually for Bob
McNamara will go back over some of this
but after the Pentagon where did you go
then I went briefly to our land Porter
because I had a lot of friends there and
because it was sort of a democratic law
firm and Abe Fortas law firm the ABE
fortis law firm oh well I should say
after the Pentagon I went to the White
House for four years I'm sorry that's
what i meant yeah and what did you mean
by that yeah Oh in the White House in
the White House Brian idea yeah I became
I was Johnson's assistant for domestic
affairs and uh you know what when he I
didn't know him when I went to work for
him the first weekend I met him at the
ranch was is just emblazoned in my head
because I I will go down to the ranch
don't know the president Lady Bird says
you ever I arrived about eight in the
morning so I left Washington about four
in the morning Lady Bird says you better
eat something because you never know
when the next meal is coming with Lyndon
and she was very nice a night then he's
in the pool he waves me into the
swimming pool gets down to the deep end
of the pool he's 63 I'm 5 10 he's
standing I'm treading water and he
starts on what he wants to do is I want
to create a transportation department
transportation system the country's a
mess bangi it's me on the shoulder
pushes me down and he says he said I
want to I want to show that we can
rebuild the cities of America bang hits
me pushes me down again and then he
starts and we're going to have a fair I
want a fair housing bill so whether
you're black or white or red or green or
purple you can live in the same place
and he with every color hits my shoulder
I'm going down gasping for my for breath
engine and he says now can you do all
this can you do all this for your
present I said yes mr. president had no
idea how I didn't it was just incredible
that was my my entrance I didn't we
didn't get to sleep that night
incidentally until about three a.m. in
the morning he just kept going and going
and going all day and four years with
him for years putting those Great
Society programs together and and trying
to get him working how old were you then
I was 34 when I went to the White House
and just just 34 was he you know you
know it was incredible because I was
brought up in Brooklyn an entirely
different world you know we're honest I
mean my parents weren't poor but they
were middle class we you know it was it
was it was punchball it was ring alivio
it was kicked the can it was all these
games you play on the street in brooklyn
and in this great Texas Washington
presence but I was lucky I had a lot of
breaks a few he gave me some tricky
tasks to do and and they all worked out
well how long were you in the abe fortas
Arnold and Porter law firm very briefly
I went there after a while you know at
the end when getting away from Johnson
is no mean tricked and he he he he
wanted me to go down to Texas and run
the library and start the school of
public affairs and I I was exhausted
worked almost every day for through
almost four years so I so I like
somebody said to me you got to get a job
because he's President Johnson started
calling around telling people don't hire
Joe for two years he's coming with me so
I Paul Porter I knew I made it dreaming
with Paul Porter went over our own
Porter and was there I walked into the
firestorm battle over whether Abe Fortas
should come back when he came off the
court and i met at williams
I had meant actually through Katherine
grain I mean Catherine grain call me
when I was at the White House and said
you know President John is going to name
the first mayor of Washington we just
passed the law she wanted to be Williams
and the president wasn't about to do it
so I said k it's not going to be
williams president wants he's white we
want to name a black he doesn't know
anything about cities and he's
representing bobby baker who was one of
Johnson's aids and throw them at that
point she chief said well don't you want
to meet him I says no point in medium no
you have no time when you're on the
White House and that kind of a furious
thing but she was was a little miffed so
she would put Eddie Williams in May at
the same table at her dinner parties and
then we got to know each other and we
started we were both workaholics so we
started having lunch on Saturdays and
finally he and I and paul connolly
formed a partnership Williams Colleen
Califano on a handshake not no not a
piece of paper we never had a piece of
paper there you've got pictures in the
book this particular one of your a bunch
of your what you would say I guess
cronies right from left to right art
buchwald David Brinkley jaktal any
edward bennett williams and you what
year was this taken this was heads 19
this was his 66th birthday so it would
probably have been in the late 70s early
80s what was he known for besides owning
part of the wrist oh well he was the
greatest criminal lawyer of his
generation he was fantastic who do you
represent well he represented Jimmy
Hoffa he represented John Connelly he
represented Joe McCarthy and and when we
when we when we formed the partnership
one of the things we really wanted to do
was represent the Washington Post and
ultimately we became the council for the
Washington Post and that turned out to
be a fantastic thing for me even more
than for him because his he he loved all
the amendments to the Constitution but
he was really focused on the 6th in
criminal justice and he and he had a lot
of misgivings about the way that press
exercise their First Amendment right so
I became the Washington Post lawyer and
the first
where and when when Watergate broke I
ended up representing the post and
Woodward and Bernstein and protecting
the sauce deep throat I want to come
back to but briefly and we'll try to get
a lot of the stuff you went on to be the
Secretary of Health Education and
Welfare the last one with that title in
the Carter Administration how long were
you there is there 30 months it was a it
was it was it's a fantastic job I mean I
really I wanted to show the Great
Society programs could be run they were
starting being complaints about them and
so I really loved that job were you
smoking four packs of cigarettes going
in I was smoking four packs of
cigarettes working for Lyndon Johnson I
used to keep I see two packs of cancer
one pocket two packs of mentholated
cigarettes in the other pocket when
throat god what was unbelievable I was
down to about two packs a day but I was
smoking a lot I stopped in 1975 because
my son who's now an orthopedic surgeon
at Johns Hopkins not orthopedic ahead
and neck cancer surgeon Johns Hopkins my
son Joe was 11 years old his birthday
was right after Christmas I said Joe
what do you want for your birthday he
said I want you to quit smoking die so
we never had a proper present what do
you really want said dad I really want
you to quit smoking so I came back and
quit in 1975 two years before i went to
a GW but what happened what what kicked
off the anti-smoking campaigns we wanted
to send got health promotion disease
prevention and i got i did a survey and
found out that ninety percent of the
people who are hooked on cigarettes were
hooked while they were teenagers and
about sixty percent of people who smoke
tried to quit within the last year but
they didn't and that led to the big
public campaign and the big anti-smoking
campaign every doctor told me we had to
wear to smoking if we want to do health
promotion and all hell broke loose and
people forget in those days there was
nobody with us I mean I was alone I mean
I I when I made a GW smoke-free the
first public building in the country
race away to go smoke-free I had
complaints within the department from
all over the department people the
Social Security Administration complain
and and then the tobacco industry went
nuts to put it mildly did Jimmy Carter
far you yes why I think that was a large
part of it what in mid seventy nine
Eastern Time 79 I remember Teddy Kennedy
1979 good friday actually having us
having lunch with him he said you got to
get out of the administration he said
the president can't carry North Carolina
or Virginia or Kentucky or maybe even
Georgia his own state and maybe even
Connecticut with you sitting there it's
tobacco thing I kind of wrote that off
because I looked at Teddy and I said you
know he's running for president he's
going to run against Carter he'd love to
unravel the administration had me go and
then Tip O'Neill called me up to his
office and he said you know you have
these tobacco guys so manager they could
kill you you know tip had that Irish
view of you know very sort of sinister
forces he said they could kill you he
thought they could murder me and then
the president called me in and you know
for a variety of reasons but it was
fundamentally the smoking issue I hacked
into his credit I have to say many years
later at a dinner in New York he pulled
me aside and he said Joe I want you to
know about smoking you were right and I
was wrong and if I can ever do anything
to help I will you talk a lot about
money in the influence of it on your
book and just to jump back to something
we were talking about earlier when you
tried to get a hospital or a school
actually a school to deal with your your
organization now that do to eliminate
smoking and and things like that you
went to New York University John beretta
misused to be a congressman I ran it but
he didn't want your center there because
of why Larry tish was the chairman of
the board and he's also was the his
company also on lorillard tobacco which
made major cigarette and y'all he also
on CBS at the time any on CBS and and
when I made it clear that we intended to
go after tobacco as well as drugs and
alcohol John in in the sophisticated
indirect way you send a signal
made it clear that it would create a lot
of tension with Larry tish I was on the
board of New York University at that
time so I and I ended up at Columbia and
Columbia has all the graduate schools
and it's the right it's the right place
but when you mentioned CBS you're now
married to a woman it's pictured here in
your book by name of Hilary and her
father was bill Paley the founder of CBS
and among other things you write in the
book that you were at his bedside when
he died I was in his bedside it was the
first time I saw anybody die he had he
suffered from cigarette illness
emphysema he had been a heavy smoker he
had stopped smoking when he had a
problem with one of his long as years
and years before and he he hung on that
there were so many things about his
death that had a tremendous impact on me
I mean one was when he was done when he
was close to dying and they were sick he
had six children and we were in his
apartment and this and the doctor said
you know he's not going to live and the
issue is whether to unhook him he turned
his apartment into a intensive care unit
he had tubes to feed him tubes to take
care of mantas waste to sell them
breathe tubes to mix his blood I'm
interested kredel drain his blood he was
bleeding internally and five of the kids
said yes and one trial said no daddy
wants to live he wants to hang on and
one of the doctor said well yes he
doesn't even want the chair doesn't want
to lie down he wants to sit up so he
doesn't fall asleep or die away so the
kids all every child said then let him
let it be then we came back my wife had
a premonition the day we went back we
went back to his apartment that night
and you know I watched this man of
enormous power who had every every need
he wanted in his life satisfied and
I just I've never seen anyone die before
I mean you know I just collapsed because
whole body just collapsed into death
hillary was there after his funeral and
memorial service we were walking along
Fifth Avenue and Hillary says you know
you don't have to practice law anymore
you don't have to make all this money
anymore I know your champion at the bit
you can do what you want to do and you
can try and to deal with this addiction
problem if you want to because I now can
take care of my kids and that was it I
mean at that moment I knew I was going
to start casa one of the things I kept
asking is I read your book is why do you
want us to know all this cuz you go in I
mean we're not even scratching the
surface sir you're telling us a lot
about your personal life about your
religious life and about your
professional I wrote this book for my
children and my grandchildren and I mean
one I want people to know there's an
incredible land of opportunity my mother
was a schoolteacher my father started
IBM as a secretary and was an
administrative assistant when he retired
you know 30 years later I didn't know
anybody when I went to Washington I
didn't know sigh Vance when I wrote in
the letter applying for a job and and
and look what happened it was the only
in America in something like this happen
I mean you represent the Washington Post
the Democratic Party during Watergate
you have you know have all these other
experiences and the other the other
thing was I think it's very important
for people with public power to have a
moral compass that might happen to be my
Catholic faith and what I believe in it
there are lots of different moral
compasses and people have them but it is
important to have that you can't
exercise public power a morally it's
especially in a democracy and especially
where government is now so powerful did
you keep notes through these years I
tell you what i did i kept i had i had
525 boxes legal sized boxes of material
when we started on this book that I'd
collected from the beginning I kept all
my letters when I went and a current
went winning something would happen that
I felt was a moment momentous incident
I'd make a memo for the record I mean
when for example I right in there about
meeting but Jaworski calling me over
when he was the special prosecutor to
sort of feel me out it's so I indicate
that he you know he had Nixon cold when
he told me a running made me have a
runaway grand jury and you know how
would the Democrats react how would the
post people react sort of i come back
from meeting like that and immediately
dictate a memo for the record I'm I
didn't know I was ever going to write it
or not it just struck me that this was
incredible and so I I did that when I
worked for Lyndon Johnson Johnson would
tell you to do nine different things at
the same time you know we tell you we
tell you wanted a bit major draft a
major civil rights bill call it the
steel the steel companies roll back the
price of steel and get the door fix the
door squeaking I mean so I used to have
these sort of steno pads would fit in
your pocket and I you'd write it all
down I kept all those pads and they're
all at the LBJ Library now it's hard for
a lot of people to read it was hard for
me to read some of them but 40 years
citizen could go down there and ask for
those steno pads and look at them any
citizen can look at them and everything
that's cited in this book and everything
in support of what's in this book either
is or will be at the LBJ Library and I
think it's organized and according the
chapters in this book but i did i did
had i had an enormous amount of stuff
and you know it's very important because
you don't remember things you think
something happened in nineteen
sixty-five you find out it happened in
1972 and you wonder how you could ever
you know how something like that could
ever have here's an incident i actually
first read this in the New York Daily
News I'm sure you've gotten feedback on
this about halfway down the aisle a
young woman with dark hair and thick
rimmed glasses abruptly came in front of
me and said quote you sold out you MF ER
you sold out unquote I didn't use the
actual words for obvious reasons I kept
walking pretending to ignore her two and
a half years later at 11am on Monday
March nineteen nineteen seventy three
that same young woman walked into my
office at Williams Connolly and Califano
for a job interview it was Hillary
Rodham you obviously remembered what she
said to you I know I won't forget it you
have to and I'll answer it I offered her
a job and she said well she thought
about and then she said no I'm going to
go to Arkansas but that was the summer
of nineteen seventy-two it was the most
anti-establishment summer I think in the
history of Washington I walked into the
Senate caucus hearing about migrant
workers with the president of coca-cola
coca-cola was being assaulted for not
handling migrant workers properly in
Florida they did straighten it out and
the anger in that room was palpable you
could feel it I mean you you could walk
down the aisle with the chair of cocoa I
felt hated everybody in that room hate
us so that when that woman came up to me
she sort of captured the whole room and
it was seared on my mind needless to say
i had no idea or she was at that time
and when up when she walked in my office
are you surprised at the language used
no because remember we you know sure
it's rough language but we're talking
about angry young people who were trying
to change the world all the four letter
words were you know we're coming we
after in the late 60s and early 70s we
had this revolution in the use of
four-letter words in this country and
women started using them as much as men
and men start especially the young ones
it was an angry time here's another
incident of another famous American late
that afternoon Moyers set up a
conference call with treasury secretary
henry fowler who had just assumed his
post and me Moyer said the DNC would
backdate a check and he wanted us to say
that the bill had been paid and the
story was incorrect is that is that was
at a crime uh no I don't think it was a
crime but what's the story well the
story was this the Democratic Party had
not paid the
Pentagon for the use of the presidential
use of military aircraft during the
campaign and depending on a bill and
they hadn't paid Walter Pincus a
reporter for the then for the Washington
store got the story wrote a story that
they hadn't paid Moyers who I didn't
know well at that time but he was
obviously under enormous pressure from
lyndon johnson and you could feel it in
the phone conversation and johnson was
going to prove this reporter wrong and
say the bill had been paid Fowler and I
refused to do that and then eventually
and bill finally said the check is gone
so I said okay I'll issue a statement
that says the bill was paid by a check
dated this date which was two or three
weeks earlier which I did and Walter
Pincus being a good reporter that he was
wrote the next day that the chequered
was delivered an hour before I issued
the statement even though it was dated
two weeks earlier and Bill Moyers at
that time was what to done he was LBJ's
press secretary oh no he would have been
as it would have been an assistant
because when bill became press secretary
I went over to the White House and
Walter Pincus wrote for The Washington
baldest Walter Pincus then rose for the
evenings are best of her I want to ask
if this has ever been printed before
years later when i was on the White
House staff Lyndon Johnson told me quote
Kennedy tried to kill Castro but Castro
got Kennedy first you ever reported that
before I think this is the first
reporting of that I'm a man may have
talked to people about that you go on to
say you agreed with Lyndon Johnson that
Castro through Lee Harvey Oswald killed
Kenneth I have come to believe that
Brian I'll tell you I when I was in the
Pentagon I was I served on US
super-secret committee on Cuba be set up
in January 1973 where President Kennedy
the objective was to overthrow Castro
and get rid of them it what's in the
book about those events that most of
that has never been published before I
fought to get these documents
declassified when joining them one it
was wild and we were going to weave into
all kinds of things we're going to put
we wanted sugar in their gasoline we're
gonna tell the Cubans all to turn the
aren't the same time to drain their
water at one point we considered whether
we should tie incendiary devices to the
feet of bats drop the bats over Cuba at
night they'd fly into the attics of
houses and buildings the incendiary
device would go off in the island would
go up in flames but there were clearly
Robert Kennedy was determined to
assassinate Castro it was a it was the
Kennedys were obsessed with it and what
did you do when you were confronted with
well the first time it came up once at
one of our committee meetings the
committee was the CIA the Defense
Department the State Department and the
Justice Department and the State was not
only in charge but Robert Kennedy was in
charge and when it was the only time it
was discussed in a formal way in that
committee I opposed it and Joe Dolin who
was the Justice Department was a young
Justice Department lawyer at the time
also opposed the remarkable thing in
retrospect is the CIA was completely
silent during that whole discussion but
if your Castro that you have to just
think now about November for the fall of
nineteen sixty-three there in several
attempts on your life the mob poison
pens that Creek the crazy stuff and in
September Castro told a reporter for
Associated Press you know the Americans
leaders ought to be careful because
they're going to try and kill me they're
not immune from from being killed
November 1 ZM is killed head of the
south vietnam is killed in a coup that
we sponsor that was approved by
President Kennedy so you're sitting
there in your Castro you've got to say
these guys are going to get me November
22 president kennedy is assassinated and
I think the paroxysms of grief I mean
unbelievable grief of Robert Kennedy is
a personal view but I really do believe
in it unbelievable grief is was driven
in good measure by the fact that he
thought some of the things he was doing
or what may have killed his brother I
walked I was general counsel the army at
that time one of my responsibilities was
arlington cemetery at on the saturday
after the assassination McNamara said
good overall in Saturday meet Robert
Kennedy picked the gravesite and I
walked that 3.2 acre site in the pouring
rain with Robert Kennedy I never seen a
more shadowed man I mean he was just so
unlike him unbelievable grief I mean it
was it was as though he's carrying tons
of grief on those small shoulders and I
think I think that that's really part of
it and think about this when you think
about commissions and the Commission's
we have today the Warren Commission
never talked to me or anybody else
involved in the covert Cuban program in
the course of their investigation about
that you say that leave already also
visited Russia came back through Mexico
City that's right Cuban embassy visit
writers there it's at the connection for
you that's part of the connection yes
and I think you know there's still
people working on this I think we won't
know the answer to this I hope we know
it in my lifetime but I think at some
point we'll we'll have the answer to
this but and Johnson believed it and
what mediately after Johnson became
president he ended this covert program
and I was sent around the country to see
the Cuban remade members and tell him
that it was all over and that was not a
happy that was it difficult the father
of the current press secretary the
president has written a book that says
that Lyndon Johnson had John F Kennedy
killed that's a total lie and I mean
that's that that is an outrageous thing
I think the history gender history
channel has had three historians look at
that and they have all said it sent was
an outrageous broadcast it never should
have been broadcast the history channel
is apologized to Lady Bird Johnson for
doing that I think they need the kind of
than any some kind of standards review
before putting that kind of crap on the
air has anybody accuse you of being deep
throat no and I wasn't deep true you
know I would ask that sure I mean is
there anybody that had their hands and
so many pies around Watergate than you I
don't think so but it was you know I I
filed the lawsuit three days after the
break-in we probably Democratic National
Committee lawsuit on behalf of the
Democratic National Committee we filed a
civil lawsuit why we have Larry Brian
the committee I was also it was in that
lawsuit in the and in the course of that
lawsuit that Woodward and Bernstein was
subpoenaed to identify their sauce I
argued the motion to quash that subpoena
before Judge Richie one that although
over time on behalf of on behalf of the
Washington Post the sitting in my office
one day and Alexander Butterfield who
worked for me as my f was eight when I
worked for a secretary McNamara that Air
Force lieutenant colonel at Flo's
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Butterfield
calls he says I'm in the Sheridan call
it calls and sheridan Collin barber shop
he said Joe I need you I need you to be
my lawyer in a civil way what he said
well he said I told a staff member of
the Watergate committee that the
president had this taping system which
was automatically in effect whenever
anybody spoke he was working in the
White House with Richard lettuce field
was Richard Nixon's doorman no Richard
Nixon would not take a phone call unless
Alexander Butterfield took it first
because he wanted to know even from his
wife and children Alex told me because
he knew this taping system I know
whatever what the subject was and he was
testifying for the way to give me that
afternoon I said I said Alex I can't
represent you I
the Democratic Party and now
representing the Washington Post I just
can't do it so we talked about it and
he's a straight arrow and he said what I
said just go up there alone he'll make a
hell of an impression to testify to
testify this afternoon and he said is
there anything else I should do and I
said well I said he's still in the
barbershop and he said yes I said get a
damn good haircut because it's gonna
take a hell a lot of pictures do this
afternoon so this is 73 this is 73 and
at the same time well at the same time
Al Haig I Al Haig had been my military
aid on the Cuban problems when I was in
I was with the Department the army and
then I brought him up when I worked for
Bob McNamara and his job at this time
his job he was he was at when he first
called me he was vice chief of staff of
the army and he said President Nixon
wants me to go over and be his chief of
staff the whole thing was coming apart
in any way I said you know if you do
that you'll never be chairman of the JCS
which I thought he would have been and
we talked about and we both thought he
could help the presidency in the
presidency of this country was important
we both believed in the strong
presidency so he went over there after
the Nixon gets into the battle over the
battle of the tapes is just beginning
they hadn't been subpoenaed yet they had
and how hey calls mean he says he the
other thing he had urged Nixon to hire
at Williams and me nix nix law partner
Milo pointer had Williamson me and Nixon
said no they're Democrats alcohol me and
said you know if you were me what would
you advise Nixon do about the tapes and
I said look L I'm not your lawyer and he
said yeah but just if you were me I said
if I were you I'd tell Mixon to burn the
tapes and he said well would be a
terrible problem I said look be a
terrible fire so I'm all hell break
loose I understand that but it'll be
over in three weeks now why would you
tell him that a good Democrat to do well
you know Brian I just we were very close
friends I think it was a different kind
of Washington I mean it was it was a you
know as they used to say after five
o'clock there was no partisanship but I
mean I made it clear that I wasn't his
lawyer I did say this is what I would
tell him if I
were you now Nixon did not burn the
tapes the tapes hadn't been subpoenaed
yet when did Peter Rodino the chairman
of the Judiciary Committee that had the
hearings call you and ask for advice
Peter called me after well the
impeachment procedure breath the we
started you know all the impeachment
issues they were there being raised call
Albert was was very concerned speaker
the speaker caught up was this figure I
was very concerned Agnew is resigning as
vice president as resigned as vice
president I happen to be sitting there
in the courtroom because I was
representing richard cohen on another
columnist richard columnist then he was
a metro reporter for the washington post
they were trying to find out who his
source was about the AG news stories I
was defending protecting his source but
any case back call Alberta Cohen he said
we can't have we have to get Jerry Ford
nominated and confirmed with vice
president I don't want to be the he's in
line of succession I don't want them to
think there's anything political about
the impeachment proceedings so I helped
call Albert do a statement which he said
that they get food nominated there
wouldn't be any Judiciary Committee
hearings until after that was done in
the following year and then and then
Peter Rodino who was an old friend of
mine call me up and asked me he really
asked me two things I mean one of which
everybody's in the book when he asked me
to help him find somebody recommend
somebody and I did recommend John doar
who became the chief counsel I think I
think door I think I'm sure other people
recommended door as well but I was a big
proponent of door and I think was the
first one to talk to Peter about it and
then I also said you know if you really
want to understand the workings of a
White House get butterfield up here
early on to talk to you and your staff
because he'll be able to he really knows
the interspecies of how that place ran
had it become public yet about the tapes
at that point the tapes were public yes
because he had testified in the Senate
first we first testified scraps
that's correct so you've talked to Peter
Adina advised him and but in the middle
of all this I keep reading in here that
you were always running to the
Washington Post as they every day we'd
get up in this town at 10 20 at night
you get your first paper down but they
have capital Hilton so you'd find out
what was in paper the next day but you
would vet for them whether or not it was
legal I was vetting those stories I was
constantly going over there in the
afternoon or getting a call and you know
vetting stories for Ben Bradlee and
Howard Simon's is is is not easy and
what was it what were their jobs Ben
Bradlee was the editor of the post the
executive at Howard silence was the
managing editor and every once in a
while I remember on one occasion I said
you know can't we wait until tomorrow I
don't have enough time and and and they
said no we're going to run it today I
said well let me suggest just to answer
our question and they were and when with
Woodward and Bernstein I'm n ben bradlee
coming to add Williams in me and saying
kenwood would and Bernstein talk to
grand jurors we said hell no I can't
talk to grand jurors that but we had
this mischievous twinkle in his eye and
you know and they were and Woodward and
Bernstein were constantly going after
the witnesses before the Watergate grand
jury which you can do to the point where
Earl Silbert who was the US attorney in
Washington was calling the complaining
about how aggressive they were but yeah
it was the town the town in those days
but I remember people got up in the
morning it was as bad as Bradley so it
was like a fix people want to know
whether the Washington Post have today
about water getting some people went the
night before sure you didn't have
internet then so you couldn't get it
that's right and right in front of the
Mayflower Hotel did you ever leaked to
the washington post information to you
had based on what you were picking up
all around to know the one I never told
the Post what I knew where is the
Democrat or vice versa I never I never I
told Eddie Williams just about
everything I know although I held back
from it
the one thing I did hold back from it I
did not tell that about talking an egg
about the takes why not I just thought
it was a very personal conversation
years later you know EDD went up to New
York and had dinner with Richard Nixon
and told her he should have burned the
tapes many years later and I never told
dad Jaworski called me over near the
near the end now he's the special
prosecutor he was the special prosecutor
going after president next going after
President Nixon and others and Leon
Jaworski called me over and that's one
of the times when I really did a
detailed memo and he sat down and the
first part of the conversation was about
John Conley because Eddie was
representing John Conley the secretary
of the Treasury who was indicted for
bribery and he wanted to tell me that he
had dis quality Jaworski had
disqualified himself from representing
from going after Connolly because he
knew him so well but he wanted to warn
me that he thought they had a cold case
against Colleen he wanted me to get that
message said Williams then I thought
that was the meal but turned out to be
only the appetizer then he said but he
wanted to talk about Watergate he
started any told me that he had a that
the grand jury was convinced Nixon was
guilty he had on more than one occasion
had to hold the jury back from in dining
him the grand jury was worried that the
political mechanisms in the house for
impeachment would not understand the
depth of the crimes the president
committed and he started to talk to me
about what did I think would happen if
he made some kind of a deal with Nixon
Nixon to get out and then not be
indicted and Joyce was very sensitive
about this because you may recall there
was a lot of criticism about the
arrangement with vice president Agnew on
which he was allowed he's really
indicted for bribery and a variety of
other things but he's in God to plead
nolo contendere to a tax evasion charge
which meant what I don't contest it
wasn't a guilty finding in return for
his resigning as vice president you
think he was guilty by the way Agnew of
taking money absolutely
well that's the other piece let's put
yes Brendan Sullivan listen when I'm in
the middle of all of this i'm home one
friday night and the phone rings is
brendan solid and the hottest young
lawyer in a law firm who turned out to
be a lean or Slayer later turn out
healings the guy that said I'm not what
do you think I am a potted plant that's
right okay so he's a young bright young
lawyer and Brendan Sullivan calls and
says I've got to talk to him we weren't
talking on the phone then because we
thought we might be bugged so we go out
on Brendan's both the next day and he
says let me tell you something a guy
named Alan Green came to see me
yesterday and he says he's been giving
money to the vice president hey when he
was governor of Maryland and even today
bringing him cash in brown paper bags I
said oh my god and Brendan so now in
addition everybody else were
representing we're representing the firm
is representing this guy Alan Green who
was the guy that brought down the vice
president so it was it that I don't
think there ever was a law firm in a
situation like that in the history of
this country and all through this your
marriage is starting to be in trouble
yeah I mean I then you write about this
and I do write about it the White House
years took a fearful toll I you know I
in a sense I was torn between you know I
look back on it between two goods I mean
the good of the family and the good of
the work we were doing at least as I
felt with those with those Great Society
programs for the poor and the black and
indigent and you know my reach a point
where we just had no relationship with
my wife we tried to restore it we went
on a trip around the world after the
ground grant after thee there was one
paid for by the 45-day for by the ford
foundation that trip which among other
things led to the requirement now that
foundation spent five percent of their
income a year Wilbur Mills took care
that and the fellow was running the Ford
Foundation McGeorge Bundy he worked with
in the White House I work with in the
White House okay so you're going around
the world with Trudy and and and we sort
of got it back to
gather a little bit and we had another
wonderful child Claudia or a daughter in
1971 and we're 1970 i should say 1970
and then you know when Eddie and I
became partners and I went into this
height we had this high-powered law
practice she really didn't enjoy it and
we kept separating and separating
separating and I went on it I said 'he
w-was 1979's very tough year for me I
went on this trip just fortuitously but
I went to Poland and then to Rome and
then to Jerusalem and then to Egypt and
going back through thousands of years of
civilization I began to think you know
what am i doing it just made me think
about how you know what small people we
are in the large concept of the world
and and I was miserable and she was
miserable and we separated and I never
thought I'd get married again and said
got married again you didn't get married
in catholic church because you were
divorced man and then you got some want
to ask you about this because people who
are not Catholic don't understand the
annulment okay and you've got a chapter
here we found a priest it says the
following you he said suggested to you
get your marriage annulled and you said
how can I do that I was married for more
than twenty three years before we
separated I've got three children he
said don't be so sure the church is
understanding especially if you were
married young and didn't fully
understand at the time what marriage was
all about how were you and your wife
when you got married I was 24 she was 22
and you were successful in getting me at
home well it was really quite I was very
skeptical as as the book indicates I
mean I was very skeptical about you know
and father modrus was the priest up at
st. Ignatius in New York Jesuit priest
and I went to see sister Amadeus who was
a nun at the archdiocese on first avenue
in manhattan and i was really went to
see with trepidation and she started to
talk to me and she said look what I saw
didn't feel whole with my church I was
receiving Communion
priests were giving me communion and I
my conscience was clear but I just
didn't feel whole with my church and
that was becoming important to me sister
Amedeo said look what the church looks
at is whether or not you fully
understood all the rights and
obligations of married life at the time
you entered into this it's not just a
contract it's a covenant and it requires
an intellectual spiritual and emotional
understanding of the rights and
obligations of marriage so with her I
filled out all the papers I was
interviewed by a psychologist point in
the first meeting with her you know
listen uh because I was really was
careful I said sister what is this cost
because I said you know what my view was
get kid in Brooklyn everything once you
get an homage you got a big bucks here
it's for powerful Catholics she said six
hundred dollars and I obviously look
surprised she said well if you don't
have the six hundred dollars you can pay
it in installments and if you don't have
any money at all your parish priest can
write that you can't afford to do it I
said no sister I have the 600 bucks I
was just surprised it was so little and
I went and it was examined by a
psychologist and then and then he made a
report on you know it's the only time
I've ever been to a psychologist or a
psychiatrist office in my life as a
patient in effect and then and then I
was interviewed under oath by a priest
for the tribunal Monsignor for a couple
of hours and it you know they then
appoint somebody that represents you
saying where was the meanest in saying
this marriage can be annulled they did
not he did not understand these
obligations at the time he got married
and then they were they have somebody
represent the back if you're holding a
marriage together yes he did that
shouldn't be an old and they make a
decision and then it gets reviewed on
appeal and then I was no
fight and you know people call it
Catholic divorce whatever it is it it
made a difference in my life and I think
it made a difference for my children and
I think it made a difference for my
former wife and I think it made a
difference hey I mean I think everybody
was more at peace out of time over 500
pages this is what the cover of the book
looks like Joe Califano our guest it's
called inside a private professional and
personal look at his life thank you very
much for joining us thank you